i hate intros b-star season one episode
one
we kick things off with a cryptic shot
of a small rabbit getting spooned by a
wolf jump back just a bit to where we
get the introduction of the alpaca named
tem
you don't have to remember much about
him because he gets instantly killed by
an unknown carnivore at his school the
incident at the school causes a further
divide between the herbivores and
carnivores increasing the tension
between the two
this includes the drama club which tem
was a part of but now that he's dead
they need to find a replacement for his
role in an upcoming play we then meet
ells who's wary of a grey wolf in her
class thinking that he might kill her
next
she then comes face to face with the
wolf who just so happens to be the main
character in lego she
turns out he wasn't wanting to kill her
he was just friends with tim and knew
that tem had liked elves
in memory of his fallen bro he passes
along a love letter from tem that he was
planning to give to ells
she apologizes for being so scared when
he had approached her thinking that he
was gonna kill her
this kind of prejudice is common to
legacy and he says that he's either
hated or feared by everybody the next
day we get another new character in the
big shot deer
named louie well hey man like she paid
their respects to tam we learned that
louis is apparently the lead actor in
the upcoming play and basically runs to
school he tells legacy that he has a new
task for them so they go to have a talk
meanwhile we meet the pure white dwarf
rabbit named
haru aru gets bullied by her classmates
that throw her books and mattress out of
her dorm
apparently she has a negative reputation
at the school because so many guys like
her and she's forced to eat alone
while eating another new character in
mizuchi has a bone to pick with haru
because her boyfriend had kissed her
haru tries standing up for herself
saying that it was his fault but that
doesn't stop mizuchi from harassing her
back on over to louis who tells legacy
that he needs him to fit a new costume
for temp's replacement
and yet another new face makes his debut
in the character named kai
kai busts in on their conversation
saying that he should be the one
replacing tam
louie then informs him that he's going
to be removed from the actor team which
almost results in a fight
luckily legacy is there to neutralize
the tension between the two
and prevents things from escalating
legacy is then tasked to help them keep
watch later that night while they sneak
into the theater and practice their
lines
while he's on lookout he picks up the
scent of haru his predatory instincts
take over bringing us back to the
opening scene
of the non-consensual spooning episode 2
magashi seems to be fighting with some
sort of internal struggle against his
instincts that are telling him to eat
haru he merely succumbs to the instincts
but then zoe a new character who is
temps replacement snaps him out of it
while calling to him
haru takes off running before legacy can
say anything and then he's brought
inside he finds that louis had injured
his leg while trying to save zoe from
falling
anyways the next day two guys get in a
fight in the cafeteria which procs
legacy's instincts to get triggered
again he snaps at both of them causing
one of them to start picking a fight
with him
louie steps in to deter the fight and
then we learn that louis is in the
running for b
star this is the title bestowed to the
school's hero that unites all the
students above their fear and
discrimination later on we see that
louis is trying his best to keep the
play on track but his injury is getting
worse
wigashi is sent to pick up some flowers
for the play where he runs into haru he
had
accidentally injured her in their little
run-in but when he asked her about it
she says that she can't remember what
happened
he helps her out moving some stuff
around and when she says that she wants
to repay him he doesn't know how to
respond because he just wants to keep
talking to her she kind of misinterprets
the silence for something else
saying that he's flustered she figures
he's a guy so he's probably asking for
sex so she strips down
and offers to sleep with him as payment
for his help episode 3
when she starts trying to undress him he
panics and bolts this is when he learns
about her reputation
for being kind of promiscuous but
despite that he still thinks that she's
a good person or a good animal or
whatever
later on while talking to kai legacy
learns that everybody in the drama club
has some sort of odd history
peaking his curiosity as to what louie's
past is like we see that louie's injury
is definitely getting worse right before
legacy comes to talk to him about some
of the lighting for the show luis seems
to be bothered that legacy is trying so
hard to appear harmless even though he
clearly is strong
he feels insulted that legacy is trying
to hide how much power he has even
though as a deer he has no power this
causes some reflection on legacies and
and he comes to the realization that
he's not just a monster and he's
actually developing feelings for haru
we come to the first night of the play
where louis puts on a brave face despite
his injury he fights through the pain
and manages to put on a great show for
everybody however at the finale when the
final curtain closes
louis collapses episode four the curtain
had shut before louis collapsed so the
crowd was unaware of his injury
after being examined they found that
louis had broke his leg so he can't do
the second show tomorrow
louie decides to make the bengal tiger
bill his replacement in the second
performance
they need someone to fill in for bill's
role so legacy is given the minor role
as a villain
jump ahead to just before the show
starts where legacy sniffs out something
on bill
when they are alone bill confesses to
taking some rabbit blood before the play
as some sort of performance enhancer
this pisses legacy off and they almost
get into a fight as the performance is
going on we see that it's not as good as
when louis was the main character but
they're doing fine when it's time for
legacy scene he breaks character
and attacks bill pinning him down and
punching him
bill retaliates by clawing at legacy's
back where the audience couldn't see
this cues louie to step in and break the
two up making it seem like all of it was
a part of the show
episode 5. the two of them are
reprimanded for what happened on stage
and for bill taking the rabbit blood
however they maintained the image that
everything in the play was planned out
so nobody got in trouble
we now meet legacy's friend a labrador
retriever named jack who picked up on
the fact that he wasn't acting and was
really fighting bill he also picked up
on legacy possibly being in love which
prompts a weird reaction from legacy
confirming his suspicions
we then hop on over to haru who seems to
be sleeping with louie jump ahead one
month where the set crew
are preparing for the meteor festival
they discussed that on the final day of
the festival there is a lighting
ceremony where couples that put a candle
in the meteor will live happily ever
after
meanwhile haru is still being targeted
by the toxic [ __ ] mizuchi and her
friends
like she inadvertently deters the
bullying and the two of them go out to
eat dinner together afterwards
he's struggling to ask her name while
she is struggling with her instincts
telling her to stay away from him while
heading back to the dorms they make
actual eye contact for the first time
and it's a nice moment or whatever that
leads to her telling him her name
episode six another herbivore that was
killed is on the news
putting even more attention on the
students while walking through the halls
legacy comes across
a freshman wolf named juno who's getting
bullied by some guys because she's a
carnivore he steps in to help her and
learns that she had just joined the
drama club also
now we hop on over to the club where the
sophomore carnivores are
sent to discuss the details about the
festival with the city
before they go they are warned by louis
to stay away from the black market
legacy bill
and two new characters in tao and aoba
arrive at the city
they go handle their meeting at city
hall and afterwards the boys are talking
about sex like she is pressured by the
bros into talking to juno since she had
just joined the club on the way back
they get lost
and come across an old man selling his
fingers for them to eat this reveals
that they had accidentally wandered into
the black market
the black market is the place where
carnivores go to get animal blood
and meat bill wants to indulge a bit and
eat one of the man's fingers saying it's
places like this that keeps society
running smoothly
well i guess she doesn't want to take
part in this so he runs off while he's
running he thinks back on talking with
haru he feels attraction for her but in
the back of his mind he can't stop his
predatory urges telling him to eat her
this leads to him collapsing and when he
wakes up he's chained he was taken in by
a makeshift doctor at the black market
in the new face named goheen
goheen explains that it's likely his
romantic feelings for haru could be a
manifestation of his desire to kill her
his mind might be disguising his
predatory urges as love
and a coping mechanism to justify his
desire for her goheen does what any
sensible bro would do
and hooks him up with some rabbit porn
he speculates that this could be some
sort of fetish but if this doesn't get
him aroused then it's likely the
attraction that he feels towards haru
isn't romantic
he takes the rabbit porn which i want to
enunciate on so that we all end up on
the same watch list together and on his
way back he runs into aoba who decided
against eating the finger and got out of
the market also
episode 7. we got some filler content up
ahead so i'll try to get through a fast
where we meet a hen named lego the egg
salad sandwich is that lego she enjoys
actually comes from lego this is her
part-time job and she prides herself on
having the best eggs like if she said
something bad about her eggs but it was
a misunderstanding so now it's all good
now we see haru getting it on with louis
prompting a flashback of how the two met
haru had came across louis after his
horns were knocked off
he informs her that he plans on getting
fake horns and in the meantime she tends
to his injuries
after inadvertently coming on to her the
two of them start banging each other the
downside is that he was taught that it's
his duty to continue his lineage
his family had already arranged a wife
for him and apparently despite their
relationship haru was aware of this and
is okay with it
after clapping some rabbit cheeks louie
is on his way out where he runs into
lego she who came looking for haru louie
says that she isn't there and makes up a
story saying that they were just friends
louie also encourages legacy to go talk
to juno which the two ended up doing
later on they wind up practicing their
choreography together where juno comes
to the realization that she has feelings
for him when she asks if he feels it too
the sentiment kind of goes over his head
implying that he's not that into her the
next day jack had came across his
rabbit porn forcing legacy to explain
his confusion about his feelings towards
haru later on while working on the
festival haru approaches him asking for
his help since she's the only one in the
gardening club he refuses thinking that
for now it would be best to maintain a
safe distance from her however while
working lego she sees louie
interacting with haru in the distance
this makes him realize that there's
something going on between the two of
them his jealousy confirms to him that
she isn't just some prey but he's
actually in love with her
episode 8 haru and legacy end up being
some of the last students to leave the
festival grounds so they head back
together when the two of them tried to
talk about how haru tried to seduce him
when they first met they end up getting
into an argument she says that he can't
understand how she feels and why she
came onto him that day so she tries to
leave when he goes to
stop her bystanders mistake the
altercation as him harassing her so the
two have to make a run for it to avoid
being arrested
afterwards they calm down and she admits
to lying about not remembering the night
when he attacked her
although she still doesn't know it was
him he contemplates coming clean about
everything but decides against it
fearing that if she knew it was him then
she might stop talking to him
after everybody had left louis agrees to
help juno rehearse a bit but she seems
to be up to something it's nothing that
bad she just pins louie down and
declares her intention to become the
next b
star and get legacy to be her boyfriend
nothing really comes from that though
and juno continues trying to make her
moves on lego she
shortly after there's a sudden blackout
and everybody is forced to stay together
like
she realizes that haru could be off by
herself so he goes looking for her
following her scent when he finds her
she mistakes him for louis and hugs him
just as the lights are coming on
he ignores the mistaken identity but
while talking juno finally understands
that
he might have a thing for haru ye
episode 9. we get a short look at
louie's dark past that he keeps hit in
when he was younger he was held captive
to be carnivore food on the black market
after trying to protect one of his
friends from being killed an adult named
ogama who was also the head of the horns
conglomerate decided to adopt him he
imprinted on louis the goal to change
the world which louis doesn't take so
lightly
and explains why he's so influential at
school back on up to the present where
louis is nearly attacked by a carnivore
lugashi manages to prevent the attack
without louis even knowing about it when
he talks to the carnivore he learns that
it's likely that louis will become the
next b
star with an herbivore as the beast
start the carnivores fear that they
might lose some of their influence
this has led to a handful of them
deciding that they want to kill louie
like she takes on the new goal of
keeping louie alive and watching his
back
afterwards he sets up a meeting with
haru to confess his feelings for her at
the festival well alone thinking things
over haru is then abducted
some of the students had come across her
shoe and the news of the kidnapping ends
up reaching like a sheep the culprits
are revealed to be working with the
shisha gumi
a gang of lions who had kidnapped her to
feed her to their boss
apparently she's some sort of delicacy
so the boss forces her to strip naked
and bathe in preparation for his meal
over the louis who is informed of the
situation by the mayor the mayor doesn't
plan on doing anything about it though
saying that she's a goner and he wants
to keep things on track with the
festival
this is a lesson for louis to understand
that some things have to be hidden from
the public he also bribes louis saying
that if he goes on like nothing is wrong
then he'll delete the records of his
dark past in the black market
like she comes looking for louis to help
him get her back
but when he reluctantly refuses things
escalate until the two of them get into
a fight
episode 10. she goes on by himself to
look for her in the black market he ends
up getting attacked by some muggers but
then is saved by goheen
after explaining the situation to gohin
goheen doesn't want to help him but he
does find the lions hideout he gets into
a fight with one of the lion henchmen
and is nearly killed but gohan steps in
and saves him with his crossbow
fight sequence ensues where the two of
them fight through all of the lions to
get to haru
back on over to haru who is reflecting
back on her life thinking that she's
about to be killed we learned that she
had always been
seen as a small helpless animal that
would die first if anything went wrong
the only time that she felt like she was
being treated like herself and not
somebody to be pitied is when she slept
with a guy
this set her down her promiscuous path
because it was the only way she knew how
to escape feeling like a helpless animal
that was just there to be pitied
as she's reflecting on all of this she
realizes that the only one who didn't
make her feel that way was legacy
we get some anime cliches in the last
scene as she's about to die but then
legacy busts in to save her
episode 11. like she fights with the
boss and for the first time he embraces
his dark side which leads to him mauling
the [ __ ]
after the fight was done we learned that
legacy purposely didn't kill the boss
because he didn't want to be a murderer
which is a nice sentiment or whatever
but it almost gets him killed because
the boss nearly shoots him as they're
leaving
luckily louis is there to save the day
preventing the shot and proceeds to
shoot and kill the boss for what he had
done
after all the drama haru and like she go
out to get some food
they end up missing the last train so
they have to go find a hotel to stay out
for the night the two wind up in a love
hotel and while their legacy finally
comes clean about being the predator
that had attacked her when they first
met
she explains that she had a hunch it was
him and was pretty wary of him but since
she enjoyed spending time with him she
just kept it to herself
things started to get kinda hot and
heavy but it gets put to an end when
haru's instincts prevent her from
sleeping with him her body apparently
was moving on its own like it was
wanting to be eaten by him sounds like a
[ __ ] excuse to me yeah episode 12.
she offers to try ignoring it and
sleeping with him anyways but
i'd probably feel kind of rapey so he
decides against it nothing ends up
happening and the two head back to
school we see that a new rivalry has
ignited between haru and juno
later on while everybody is preparing
for the festival legacy learns that
louis is missing and nobody has heard
from him but i guess the show must go on
so the drama club does their performance
and legacy meets with haru to officially
confess his love to her they get
interrupted though when he's pulled onto
stage to be acknowledged for saving haru
after that juno tries convincing him to
light a candle in the meteor with her
he's like [ __ ] that and goes to find
haru instead the two of them talk about
their fear of their instincts which
leads to him saying that he needs to get
stronger so that he doesn't succumb to
them she just responds that she'll be
waiting we get a quick shot of louis
who's in the paper and is still missing
and in the last couple of scenes after
the credits and unseen character
that's friends with legacy is giving off
some creepy vibes by smiling for no
reason
i'm gonna be doing the next season and
you can find that on the left side
whenever i'm finished with it or you can
check out all the beats stars recaps in
the playlist on the right side you can
also find the links in the description
below and the only thing i hate more
than intros is outros